[Applause]
you used to call me on post Malone okay
Malone this guy look at him they're on
the red carpet in sort of a stone that's
who you love that's the suit I want to
get okay
this guy knows a thing or two or at
least thinks he knows a thing or two
about style and the gift that he's given
this time is Crocs everybody's favorite
rubbery shoe that right there are post
Malone's custom Crocs he's got a
partnership with Crocs and those are the
post Malone Crocs that he's released now
they cost about 60 bucks and here's the
thing he released these yesterday they
are all sold out I can't believe it
because you know what you'll wear those
first off you wouldn't listen let me
tell you this right now if you catch me
in a pair of Crocs slap me I am never
not putting on Crocs for anything yeah
yeah you're not a croc but I mean
Bearpaw it's a part of his whole
merchandise thing going on and if you
love post Malone I guess I can see why
but he wears Crocs all the time he says
he wears them on stage she wears them at
home so I guess it was you know the
right thing to do a deal with them look
I'm not surprised that post Malone wears
Crocs on stage I'm just saying he has
this tweet here can we pull up this
tweet his tweet about gibbets maybe
somebody home can explain this to me he
says yeah also I love how on Twitter
he's beer bongs and Bentley's by the way
that's Bueller he says you can tell a
lot about a man by the jib it's on his
Crocs I had to asked one of our
producers I said what is a jib it and
she's like I think it's I think it's the
thing that you poke through the role in
a croc which to me makes it a charm for
a croc it's so interesting because I
love croc jewelry i look i'm just still
stuck on the croc part ok sucks I don't
but I vote you can tell a lot by a man's
shoes and honestly I would not I mean I
would not be interested in so it's like
a first date you're meeting up with a
guy you meet him at the restaurant
he's he's dressed really nice looks good
he's like hi nice to meet you and you're
like I'm Elysia and then you see that
he's gone on a pair of post Malone cross
are you a doc
do you have a PhD what do you think in a
medical PhD I want no no I feel
disrespected on it no no crocks on dates
no no somebody else was into these
crocks though let's pull this up this is
from Instagram
Madonna reached out on Instagram and
said that she also wanted a pair of
these Crocs she actually commented on
the post like I like to imagine Madonna
herself picking up her phone right
oMG I love those how can I get some and
then Crocs of course is like yo Madonna
slightly these themes yeah maybe
Madonna will come out with the pair of
Crocs eventually I would not be
surprised to see Madonna in anything
well Joe crocks Drew Barrymore is an she
has Crocs February 1st 2018 Drew
Barrymore's Crocs color-block collection
drop they're adorable
I like those I'm here for four women
wearing Crocs your hair making but
that's okay that's holdup is it okay for
women to wear Crocs man that sounds
really bad
you can wear whatever you want look you
can wear whatever you want I'm just
telling you my personal preference in a
man I just don't prefer my men to wear
Crocs but yeah drew Barrymore Crocs are
found at DSW if you want a pair why are
you laughing
look I'm just saying
[Music]
[Applause]